hi there oh I better take these guys out
of and listening to some Arabic um yeah
tonight this morning I want to talk
about as we're approaching the end of
our 90-day challenge okay so what I want
to do is I want to have a discussion
with the tutor where I gotta show you
how I struggle still to speak Arabic and
Persian so in order to warm up for
college okay so to warm up for this so I
don't do too badly I've been doing more
listening and I've had more sort of
online sessions with tutors to practice
speaking and so then this always raises
in my mind the question of you know this
relationship between output and input in
language learning there's no question in
my mind that we learn through input
there's no question in my mind that the
emphasis on output at the early stage of
learning a language is not necessary and
possibly counterproductive
I noticed now for example that when I
speak with my tutors in Arabic and in
Persian I'm able to enjoy the session
one hour much more because I understand
better what the person is saying I have
more words that I can use many words
that I don't have or that I have
forgotten in it that I struggle to find
and that often my tutor then provides me
in my report and I review them and I
forget them again however I have this
feeling now that I'm in better control
in my conversations with my tutor and
it's a wonderful feeling it's a
wonderful feeling I didn't feel that way
when I first started speaking now in
order to get to where you can feel
comfortable of course you have to speak
as well but I only speak once a week so
one hour a week is not why I am starting
to feel more and mark
it's because of my continuing you know
listening and reading and in particular
I decided that towards the end of my
90-day challenge rather than doing three
days of Arabic and then three days of
Persian I've kind of focused a bit more
on Arabic I'm further along in Arabic
and yet in some ways Arabic is about not
some ways it is harder and so I've kind
of been going now almost for a week on
Arabic and I'm gonna in fact to have a
discussion at eleven o'clock with an
Arabic tutor and then I'm gonna switch
to Persian and so I might even film on
my iPhone myself sort of speaking Arabic
both for my own records and I might take
some of that and post it here I think
it's better rather than trying to get
the Skype recording where you get
different sound levels and fuzzy screens
and whatever if I film it on my I've got
a handy little you know tripod here if I
film myself just my end of it so you can
hear the tutor in the background very
lightly but you can't hear what he or
she is saying and then you'll see me
struggling to speak either Arabic or
Persian so they'll be in a sense might
call up my testimonial or my you know
demonstration of what I have achieved
which I will keep for my own record
because a year from now I would you know
look at that and it'd be an indication
of how much I've advanced plus when you
watch yourself speak you pick up a lot
of your mistakes so I'm going to do that
so so that and as I do that so I notice
now that as a result of speaking and as
a result of the cumulative sort of
effect of all of the listening and
reading so I lost I noticed more and
more things and now that we have the sir
you can listen to your whole course at
link so I just go to as Samia which I
have uploaded into link and listen to
the audio of the course and I started
lesson say 50 in s email I go up to 76
then it flows back to one you know one
maybe not but by lesson 10 there are
always things there that I hadn't yet
noticed I hadn't fully realized so the
whole process of learning and language
it's not like you know other things
where you learn this basic thing you
have to learn to add and subtract before
you can learn engineering or something
you know
whereas with languages it's not obvious
that one tense is more difficult than
another that there are certain things
that are basic and then you build on
that the only thing you really have is a
sort of frequency like some very common
words are gonna appear more and more
often
and familiarity in other words if the
subject is more familiar you're gonna
understand a little bit better but you
know in Arabic for example they start
with the past tense that's the first
tense that's introduced in just about
every book that I looked at and yet we
tend to assume say in European languages
that we should begin with the present
and then move on to the past tense at
the past tense it's more complicated
it's not more complicated
nothing is more complicated really they
are all difficult for us to grasp at
first you know and and then through a
lot of exposure and then being familiar
with these things because we've seen
them then we notice things that we
didn't notice in the first pass when
they start an Arabic grammar book and
they tell you that they're all these
different kinds of verbs and it's it's
all lost on you and I should add another
thing yeah so I think familiarity is
extremely important as we develop a
strategy of how much input and how much
output we want because obviously the
output stimulates the input so the
output it makes you aware of things and
then you're a little more attentive when
you're listening so you do need some but
when you introduce the output I'd like
how often you're gonna speak to a tutor
how often you're gonna speak this is
going to be part of your strategy and I
dug but I don't know if there is us sort
of a magic formula of how much input and
how much output at what stage maybe one
day they'll come up with that as a guide
but I think the best guide is what you
feel like you want to do so some people
are more inclined to want to use a
little bit that they have and other
people are more inclined to want like I
am to build up greater confidence in the
language more vocabulary better ability
to understand so that then we can feel
more comfortable when we have these
conversations and I think we get more
out of them
because if we have more words and we
understand more then the range of our
conversation can be so much broader
we're not simply talking about the
weather and where I live
we're talking about a whole variety of
things and I sort of feel a sense of
power as I'm struggling and I think we
all do is I'm struggling to say things
and I find that I am able to say certain
things and certain words come out of
nowhere and other words come out and
they're wrong and then the teacher
corrects someone but so that you know I
prefer to at least have a chance to have
a meaningful conversation so I wait but
other people maybe they prefer to get
started early I don't think there's an
absolute formula there but we learn from
the input of that I am certain and
something else that I think is very
important is like when I started with us
email they have a lot of content that is
you know folktales or from 2000 or right
one night or something it's very much
part of Arabic culture and I think
there's a great tendency on the part of
people who write textbooks to give you a
lot of culture rich content early I
noticed this with Chinese you know fast
or even in Japanese festivals and all
this kind of stuff and I think that's a
very bad strategy because it's very
important to keep things as familiar as
possible that's why I love our mini
stories if you have a familiar
background people going to work making
breakfast cleaning up the room these are
all situations that are familiar to us
and so therefore at least the context is
familiar and so then we have an easier
time you know trying to learn the new
words and the new structures of the
language I now find that the lessons in
us
which initially I didn't like because
they were too exotic now I find them
interesting because I have a better you
know a higher level in the language a
higher level of comprehension so I'm not
struggling against an unfamiliar
language and unfamiliar context things
that I just totally don't understand so
now I'm enjoying those so I think in
terms of the input as well people talk a
lot about graded readers and I think
it's good to have the material graded to
some extent but it's also important to
start from the familiar and then move
towards the less familiar as we proceed
through this sort of input strategy and
I remain you know I will continue input
not only is it the most effective way to
learn in my opinion but it's also the
easiest to organize I have to set up
discussions on link or on I talky I have
tutors on both now I have to try to
remember where I have already you know
book the discussion so that there's no
conflict I talk he doesn't have the
easiest interface in the world so it's
always a little bit we can probably
improve our method of link for
interacting with tutors but it's it and
you have to pay them so a couple of
hours a week is plenty where else the in
the listening I just pick it up and I do
it wherever I am and every time I listen
and every time I read the language is
becoming more familiar and I'm noticing
more and more things and it's building
up in me a better and better ability to
speak but ultimately of course I have to
speak and so nearing the end of my 90
day challenge in Arabic compersion iwata
as I promised that I would you know have
a little short video of me using these
two languages so I'll put those up
either at the end of this week or
Finance Monday next Monday is probably
next Monday or Tuesday the last day of
the 90 day challenge
I noticed by the way that someone had
posted there a video of them speaking
Mandarin after a certain period of time
I haven't had a look at it yet but I
will have a look at it and if any of you
want to post
examples of the results of your 90 day
challenge ideally do it on the forum
I've often felt that we should have at
link in our profile and maybe it's
something we'll eventually get to sort
of a portfolio where we put sort of
recordings of ourselves speaking the
language at different stages of our
learning and this portfolio is something
to be with control so if we want we can
have in private or we can have some of
them made public so people can see what
our level is in the language in a way
you know if you can speak for five
minutes
on video that's the best measure of how
good you are in that language far better
than any TEFL tehsil or IELTS or all
these other tests in my opinion however
the advantage of Tefilin tehsil is that
if you're a Japanese employer it doesn't
speak English very well yourself here in
no position to judge someone's ability
in English through a video and therefore
at least you know TEFL or not temple but
what's that it's called TOEIC gives you
a so-called objective evaluation and
that's why it's useful okay I will stop
there and I'll see what people have to
say and I may be leaving early today
because I have an arabic tutor at 11:00
and i want to spend half an hour warming
up by doing a lot of listening and
reading and going through some of my
lessons on link so let's have a look and
see what we got here all right so first
bla bla bla how long have you been using
link my German learning is just simply
reading and listening that I put on a
link right now kinda passive I don't
know what straight I'm actually
improving you're improving never worried
about the rate at which you're improving
it's cumulative and you don't notice it
you'll notice it when you compare
yourself to say three months earlier how
do you get foreign language content
until link Scott asks I don't know this
is a general question or it's for the
specific participant here but I find it
online and I imported
and I use the the import you know widget
or extension I do it both on my iPad and
with the computer many YouTube channels
have some I know yes so YouTube channels
have subtitles that those make excellent
lessons that link you can automatically
import them by simply clicking on the
extension browser extension yeah Marilyn
says he puts them private yes you can't
share anything that is not free of
copyright
hibari but from Amazon and French and
they wouldn't sell to me I don't know
why that would be I've bought books in
many languages
I don't like ebooks because they come
along with audio I don't understand that
Marlon I look for ebooks for which I can
also buy the audiobook and if anyone is
learning Italian L&R Authority offers
audio ebooks so you can get both the
ebooks are good because if you download
a dictionary you can pouch the word in
the difference okay and I mr. Steve good
afternoon you have Lola you are right
the close together doesn't exactly match
yeah if the coast captioning doesn't
exactly match it's not so important
you're learning a bunch of words people
get hung up about accuracy
I don't their words you need them anyway
sir may you I cease not if I'm most
efficient provide audio two words
appetizer exercise sir may you repeat it
because I have a paper I don't
understand
may you repeat it I don't understand I
have my video and you can listen to it
as many times as you want I think there
are even subtitles if you want you can
even import it into link in a recent
session you said your wife was quite
unhelpful kind of and I'm glad to see
someone else has felt my partner's
pottery and no help at all yes Aaron
don't expect if you have been in the
habit of speaking to your wife or
partner in whatever language your
language or language a third language
and you start studying her or his
language don't expect them to help you
you're not gonna break those habits okay
what new language you're learning right
recently I'm learning
Persian and Arabic when will you
consider learning Turkish I said I would
do that starting in the new year now I
may even add Turkish and Hebrew because
one of our members at link has provided
us with a whole bunch of good content in
Hebrew so we'll see what the new year
brings but when I I'm gonna have to
pause my Arabic and Persian because I'm
going to Ukraine and anima I want to
work on improving my Slavic languages
Ukrainian and Russian interests in this
case and then because I'm going to the
Fukuoka polyglot conference I want to
just raise the level of my Korean so I
think that'll be my emphasis until
October and then I'm gonna get in I'll
probably get back to our become Persian
starting a bit of Turkish and I might
hold off on the Hebrew otherwise I'll
just get too confused what is early
stage to try out click well I used to
wait till I have you know eight ten
thousand words but I have found that
with the mini stories where it's there's
so much repetition and there's so many
very common verbs I've started earlier
three thousand words on our link count
so is that a - I don't know but even at
that I only speak once a week in the
early stage input must be acquired alone
without any output participation or must
be combined I don't think there's any
must here but I tend to in the very
early stages no input I can't excuse me
no output I can't output I can't say
anything I don't understand what the
person is saying so I wait till I have
at least 3,000 words on the link count
before I engage a tutor mm-hmm okay do
you think field linguists are able to
learn language faster than regular
people I don't know what a field
linguist is but I feel the study of
linguistics has very little to do with
learning languages and doesn't give you
any advantage would you like to tell me
how to improve my business English
exactly how can I build a sentence and
mayo conversation I don't know what male
conversation is but to improving your
business English you have to read more
business content business related
content
you have to save words and phrases
phrases that you would like to use and
then I would get on a with a tutor and
start talking about business you have to
start and I would write again write
about business because when you're
talking you know business English
typically is either you know the spoken
form and the written form are going to
be very close together it's not like
sitting around and having a coffee or
beer chatting about all kinds of
different things it's much more
structured and so I would do a lot of
reading on business related subjects I
would even write on business related
subjects and I would get a tutor with
whom I would simply converse about
business related subjects okay Dale on
here is it possible to reach B 1 or 2 in
Chinese living in New York if you have
friends and an environment that makes
you speak it so I don't know if you're
talking about Mandarin obviously if you
have an opportunity to speak that's a
positive thing I learned Mandarin in
Hong Kong where no one spoke man excuse
me yeah in Oregon no one spoke Mandarin
in 1968-69 so the bigger issue is how
much listening and reading are you're
gonna do in my opinion or you may just
pick up just by being with your friends
you might pick up some but but it won't
be that sort of it won't take you to a
b2 level hello Steve is it true that
reading is more important than watching
movies because I've noticed the more I
read the more my English grammar expands
yeah I'm a great fan of reading I've
said this before movies are a bit of a
distraction movies are a reward it's fun
to watch movies but we learn more from
either audiobooks or reading because
there are only words so the brain has to
imagine what the meaning of those words
is and that's much more powerful in my
opinion than watching movies move to
Toronto and roll unironic because full
of Chinese is pretty yeah yeah the
universe around was full of Chinese yes
unfortunately in Canada there seems to
be a policy of bringing in as many
foreign students as possible many of
whom are Chinese and it does detract a
bit from in my opinion and this might be
controversial from the kind of
atmosphere you'd want to have at a
Canadian university
Tenace for those papers to stick within
their own group and not really become
part of the general university community
but if you do too much input pretty sure
you can't achieve B Y in any language
within six months no that's not true
Marlin I focus on input and you can
judge based on an hour a week over the
last three months of talking to a tutor
but certainly input for the first three
months I mean my Persian has only been
three months and you'll see that I can
communicate quite well uh-ho Steve I'm
off in a situation when I watched
Russian bloggers and understand like
sixty to seventy percent but I can't
really use such construction in speech
even though I know the meaning how do I
overcome it you just have to speak more
often continue the input save words and
phrases and then just speak more often
and you're gonna struggle it's it's not
like an automatic everything that goes
in is gonna come out no you will always
have a much larger passive vocabulary
than active vocabulary because the
native speaker has far more words than
you do but you just have to continue you
just have to continue and slowly you'll
get better will you recommend learning
the Chinese characters yes I recommend
learning the Chinese characters it's
kind of a door to the Chinese world if
you can read you can learn so much
faster you can learn more words you can
acquire more vocabulary it's a lot of
work to learn the characters and it's
something you have to get at and do
everyday is it is it possible to see too
with 90 percent input and ten percent
output no this combination of input and
output the further along you are in the
language the more you have to output
because while see - I guess you
theoretically could be see - just
passively in terms of listening
comprehension and reading and if you are
you're gonna speak well but as I
progress as I reached a sort of a b1 b2
I feel a greater and greater need to
speak and
to really get to that next level you
have to speak a lot like hours at a time
so an evening with native speakers or
things of that nature you just have to
put yourself into a situation where you
are forced to use the language more
mimicking and reading out loud does
mimicking me in reading I don't have
without put yeah I mean it depends what
you like doing and what you're able to
do I have never found that I can read
out loud for any long period of time I
can't you know there is this sort of
shadowing technique I just found that I
can't continue doing it but many people
like doing it certainly keeping a small
journal is another very good thing to do
but again it depends if you are able to
continue doing it it does take a certain
amount of difficulty how are some people
able to speak 10 to 15 languages
fluently more or less in my opinion
following the same strategy that I use
anyone can do that if they devote enough
time to it do you think a person who
learns a second language will
necessarily want to learn others no I
don't think so I think probably most
people who learn a second language stop
there but I think it's possible for
people to learn many languages mmm my
nephew seven years old we live in Brazil
we only speak Portuguese how do teach
English for him he has to go to English
school about one year but his
improvement is very slow yeah I mean you
can't force seven year olds we tried
with our kids
we tried to get them to let speak you
know French whatever they resisted but
if he's in a class I would leave it like
he has to do whatever that class teacher
asks him to do my grandchildren went to
French immersion they just do whatever
they're asked to do but I think pressure
from relatives is probably not a good
thing
let him he's in that environment he'll
acquire something in the language and at
some point if he's motivated then he
will probably progress
very quickly yeah I mean writing
everyday is certainly a good thing to do
I think writing is different from
speaking so ultimately you would have to
start practicing your speaking this is
an answer to Eric Roberts until what
degree of mastery can input take you
input again it's not either/or it's just
how much of one and how much of the
other and I think like a lot of input
can take you straight to be one and then
I think you want to start talking
speaking what what is comprehensive
language or you can click on each word
for its definition so if we agree
grammar should be secondary to the
exposure process this continues
somewhere else comprehensible input is
input but the quick answer without
seeing the second part of this question
comprehensible input is input that you
have a chance of understanding at least
half so if it's totally incomprehensible
unfamiliar you that's too tough if you
can understand half of it and then you
go and click on words and see more of it
and you listen and you're still going to
understand but at least you're working
towards something that is within that's
achievable so that you have a chance of
achieving 70% comprehension so that to
me is comprehensible input it can't be
100% comprehensible otherwise you're not
learning anything
it's got to be less than fully
comprehensible is it 70% 80% if you're
using a system like Lincoln can be 50 60
% if you are reading out of a book you
want 90 95 % if you're listening and you
can get back to a text like that link
then 70 percent is fine if you're
listening you know and you don't have
any way of getting out of text you
probably want a higher level of
comprehension should I start learning a
new language only after I achieve b2 in
a previous month no although that's
probably ideal it depends on what you
feel like what your needs are I don't
think there's any hard and fast rule
learning Swedish is no different than
learning and the other language lots are
listening and reading you'll get more
and more familiar with the pronunciation
with the words and you'll just be
surprised how the language grows on you
so language learning is a sort of a
fuzzy activity it's not learning the
basics and building blocks it's exposing
yourself the brain is better at sort of
forming rules out of the chaos of the
language as opposed to understanding
theoretical explanations of the language
so don't rely on theoretical
explanations of the grammar rely on
exposing yourself to a lot of the
language that's too meowstic after
reading listening what is most important
writing or speaking well it depends what
you want to do but I tend to do more
speaking because it's easier I'm neutral
internals that we're using a phone a
word at an end of a page whose extends
the following page is not clickable are
you familiar with this cheers Ciaran I'm
not familiar with this I don't know
whether it's an Android or an iOS phone
maybe Eric can follow up Erica blink
maybe you can post about this on the
forum and but I will if I remember I
will look into it but I'm not aware of
this as an issue it isn't an issue for
me on iOS so but that's not to say I
mean I understand it it's an issue for
you you could also send a you know a
message to support at link a email and
see what they have to say why did you
decide to move to Vancouver I live in
Vancouver my wife doesn't like it when
it rains here in the winter so we go
down to Palm Springs for four months in
the winter have you been reading the
Ukrainian news it would be interesting
to know what Ukrainians think about the
recent election results Ian says well
I'm going to Ukraine in the second half
of May and it's gonna be very very
interesting an amazing result really to
have the incumbent so thoroughly closed
by an app trumped by an absolute
newcomer I found I was like hello
talking amazing but the conversation
slow because I know so little how many
words do you recommend learning before
exposures rosin yourself well as I said
I used to think eight to ten thousand
words non words at linked I now start a
little earlier because I have been using
the mini stories which I think prepare
me for speaking Jack here says thanks to
your advice have usually improved my
spanish level at link and now I have a
solid comprehension level my question is
do you recommend on separating listening
and reading you know I find I do both
you know listening and reading at the
same time especially at the early stages
when it's difficult but then gradually I
find that as I advance certainly most of
my listening is done while not really
because I'm in the car I'm doing other
activities but as I get at sort of a b2
level I just do plain listening because
I don't need this necessarily to read it
all there's not that many words that I
don't know it's not necessarily worth it
one of the things I am going to do now
with my Ukrainian well there may be more
words is I can throw the podcast from
hamazaki radio or whatever I can throw
it on to one of the automatic
transcription services and get a
transcript so I could then after
listening to it if I'm curious about
some parts that I missed bring it in you
don't have it transcribed and bring it
into link but yeah increasingly we
separate I find I separate the listening
and readings
who is your favorite polyglot don't have
a favorite polyglot I am impressed with
people who speak to language three
languages five languages ten languages
it's all I always marvel at people who
speak another language well and there's
lots of them I have a hard time express
myself about complicated topics even
though I can understand most of what
people say when I talking so should I
focus mart speaking at this point this
is English yeah I mean yeah you have to
it speaking is a different skill you
have to be able to recall your
vocabulary you have to put the words
together in a you know in an elegant way
and and so you do have to end up
speaking more Henry no no longer works
at Linc do you think you can forget
outputting language when you only do
input for
several time you get rusty I don't think
you forget but you get rusty and
depending on the language it takes me
longer and longer to warm up so the
languages that I speak the best like
French and Japanese and so forth not a
problem
you know Russian little more difficult
you know Czech Romanian is gonna be
quite difficult and I'm aware of the
fact that once I leave my Persian and
Arabic here when I go back to them
they're gonna be rusty but I have always
found that when I go back to outputting
in those languages that I end up being
better than I ever was so I'm not
worried about leaving them but yeah
sometimes you takes a bit of refreshing
of listening and eventually reading I
don't understand I need time care about
flap how to pronounce fast D I don't
understand that do you sometimes
surprise that with their trading a word
your conversation after struggling for a
while Holly Holly fuh I'm always
surprised when I'm both frustrated at
what I am unable to remember or to
recall when I know I have that word and
also surprised at words that come out
that I think are quite difficult and
low-frequency it's all quite random have
you ever tried to learn an endangered
language to help at revival no and I
don't think I would do that that's not
in my strategy of language learning
do you use mnemonic techniques to
remember those few thousand common words
no I have never found that that we worth
the effort Scott says tell us about
Ukraine when you get back we'll do so
James Cook Steve people who study
English in Mexico only motivated by the
prospect of promotional work not by the
language and culture yeah I mean that's
necessarily the case with English
because English is sort of a utilitarian
language now there are people who like
English because they like you know
American soap operas or you know English
music or something
but the English would be a language
which people learn for reasons of work
and that's fine but those same people
would learn it better if they could find
something to enjoy in the language
I mean I've heard it's hard for
presenting people original mo Spanish
where their brain don't confuse both
languages I think that it's a mindset
thing I think if Brazilians really
committed to be speaking Spanish they
have such a big advantage over non you
know Portuguese speakers if they they go
for it they can quickly become very
fluent and and initially they might
confuse or they might continue to
confuse the odd word it doesn't really
matter they can become quite to look
like quickly ok lion says when I listen
to podcast on my playlist using my phone
it tends to triple or quadruple the time
I actually listen alright again I don't
know anything about these technical
issues I will ask again if you could
comment on our forum to see if other
people are experiencing the same that
would be helpful and I'm a Portuguese
native speaker and I can't bear Spanish
too ugly to my ears
well you see if that's the attitude then
the person won't learn the language so
that's why I say it's largely an
attitude issue it's a bit like Mandarin
speakers not claiming they can't learn
Cantonese it's just an attitude thing if
they want to learn Cantonese they can
learn it very quickly because it's
agreeable to videos Thank You Manuel the
last feature good he gracias we mojo
chip but you're Jewish hiroshi
ambassador in orosco yeah bull many can
I maintain a you know a good
conversation in Russian I think so and
I'll find out because I'll be I'll be in
in Ukraine and I'll be in eastern
Ukraine and there most people speak
Russian
do you like Quebec or French accent
better you know I find that they both
had their charm and even with in Quebec
or with in France there are different
accents and I try not to be judgmental
about accents I think they're all unique
and you know Scottish Australian
southern France
Brazilian Portuguese
that's just part of enjoying the
language how far do you think I can get
in French into three months if I'm a one
at the moment into three months you can
reach be one do you think culture
affects language and vice versa does
learning a new language change your
culture and way of thinking well the
more things you know the more things you
were exposed to the broader your
perspective on things it does impact
your way of thinking if you know nothing
then you know that you're gonna have a
very limited perspective on things so
but you can certain even reading is
gonna change your perspective on things
reading in your own language so but I
find that I find that learning languages
just makes me more familiar with other
cultures makes me in a way more
sympathetic to other cultures so to that
extent it does affect my world view ah
you might wanna look at those
researchers if you're a bit nerdy
there's a lot of research on them
teaching and help each other
good yeah is there any way to reach B 2
in Mandarin if you put everything if you
put everything in that language well
yeah you can reach to B 2 in Mandarin I
mean I II I think I'm beat you in
Mandarin
any language can be learned I know lots
of foreigners who like non Chinese
speakers who necessarily grow up in a
multilingual environment who have
achieved very high levels in Mandarin
why do people assume adults learn
language by a different process than
children when it's very rare for people
to assume adults learn other things by a
different process well that's a good
question I mean adults have Advent there
are advantages and disadvantages like
the child's Bryant brain is more
flexible and that child is less
inhibited the adult has a broader life
experience the adult has broader
vocabulary in his or her own language
adult can read it can access a wider
variety of subjects so to that extent
the learning experience is different but
I think the process by which the brain
acquires the language in other words it
creates rules to govern all this input
that it's getting is essentially the
same
stay okay was that the English dub Rosie
laters how can you ask a question like
that what do I think of the English
spoken by brazilians
it varies all over the place I know a
Brazilian here Gabrielle whose English
is like a native Canadian so it depends
on the individual you can't generalize
okay how do you study like do you just
read or do you take notes I don't take
any notes I listen I don't understand
things understand things I go in there I
go through the lesson as I turn the page
I will often review the words and
phrases that were on that page I
sometimes will review the words and
phrases that were in the lesson using
our five activities and then I go away
and listened and listened and listened
and then there's still things that I
don't understand I go back and I read it
and I will often go back and go back and
go back to the same lesson maybe I did
you know a lesson that I did two months
ago I've got so many lessons on the go
at so many different levels
and it's just simply exposing myself to
the language Audio reading reviewing
listening different levels and slowly
things start to accumulate I'm not
native speaker and I've seen one English
if I study French for about 1/2 hours a
day how long will it take to reach how
long would it take to reach b2 from
Puerto Rico you know if you really go at
it I mean if you have a good attitude
like attitude is so important like okay
the Brazilian who hates Spanish he's not
gonna learn Spanish if you said I'm
gonna I can visualize myself as a French
speaker I want to be a French speaker if
you've got that kind of an attitude then
yeah you I think you can reach b2 in
three months the I think you can reach
b2 certainly in comprehension because
you'll have all the words you'll
struggle to speak and then you just got
to speak more and more but you've got
that tremendous advantage that you'll
have all the words in three months and
then you just got it start speaking and
you'll have difficulty but eventually
you'll get better you won't get worse
okay can I learn two languages at the
same time if at least be one of the
first language need to maintain one more
yeah I'm struggling right now
Persian and Arabic I think I would
rather be able to focus on one but it's
certainly possible to do too with will
hang out with other polyglots make you
work harder to learn more language
that's possible I don't know as a
teenager am i as good as a child with
learning languages or is my learning
style more closer to an adult's yeah a
teenager is closer to the adults you
have your brain is no longer as flexible
as talking about the age of seven or
whatever where any language can very
quickly you know be assimilated you have
a broader vocabulary you've quite a you
know broader sort of life experience so
you are more similar to to an adult in
my opinion okay Bua
do you use audible to practice I have if
I sometimes if I'm looking for an audio
book I'll find it on audible as to which
book I can recommend it depends on what
what language you're learning like I
don't go to audible necessarily but it
just seems if I'm looking for an audio
book in yeah if I'm looking for an audio
book in polish or check it Audio
Technica seems to pop up although to
wherever the source is and typically I'm
looking for audiobooks for which I can
also find an e-book do you try to
practice the people on internet like
Moses because he says that you should
keep practicing until the moon starts to
show no I have great respect for Moses I
think it's amazing the number of
languages that he explores and is able
to speak in quite well actually
but I we all have our preferences I
don't like going out and just springing
you know with a little camera and
talking to people if I happen to come
across let's say if I go into a store
here in Vancouver and the salesperson is
obviously a Farsi speaker I'll try and
speak to them in Farsi but I don't make
a special effort at it Hong Kong we saw
alone in Boise
oh okay Steve I'm let me in Japan and I
find that most Japanese people don't
want to correct me so I wonder if I'm
making the same mistake over and over
here without knowing it what can I do
don't expect people that you're speaking
with to correct you that is a completely
on
realistic expectation first of all I
believe that if I'm speaking to someone
in English and they make mistakes it's
not my role to correct them they may not
want me to correct them that person is
trying to communicate with me if I start
correcting them it's as if our
communication is not important you will
make you will correct most of your
mistakes yourself enjoy your
communication with native speakers for
that opportunity to communicate with
them and don't expect them to correct
you do you know who I Gabriel stop
making YouTube videos no and in fact he
sent me an email I'm gonna start I'm
gonna meet with him shortly and do a
video with him yeah I mean James says
yeah people not everyone is gonna be
motivated you know passionately to learn
English however if I were a teacher I've
got to try to find something that might
elicit a spark of interest because the
more emotionally connected they are to
the language the better they're gonna
learn okay so my favorite again this
whole question of why we have trouble
speaking you're gonna have trouble
speaking and the only way to get better
at it is to speak more and also to
continue with your input activities
Russian language I found the Russian
language difficult to learn because of
the complex nature of Slovak all Slavic
languages the grammar but it's a lovely
language and a very interesting one can
you become fluent any language in a year
with hard work depends on your
definition of fluent it depends on the
language writing system how similar it
is to yours but it's a good goal to have
what is if I don't have a favorite
language as a native language English
living in Poland then attending a Polish
deal do you think the teaching style in
Poland is harmful if you cannot from
Hunstanton as she speaks it yeah I mean
this is this whole the majority of
language teachers are not native
speakers and then the majority of
speakers of English are not native
speakers there is such an abundance of
in native
content available on the Internet the
teacher should be directing the students
to listen to this content III don't
think listening to people with a bad
accent is harmful as long as we're
getting enough exposure to you know
authentic you know native pronunciation
I spend most of my time in English can
you learn a language with just watching
movies no I have not found that to be
the case how many words do I need in
order to start talking again this
question has come up before but I I
think with German if you're three to
five thousand words go through our many
stories that's gonna give you a lot of
the familiar vocabulary verbs and stuff
that you need okay the Arabic podcast
that I find are on al Jazeera and France
bad cat I found them on where you call
it their iTunes Levantine Arabic are
you'd have to google there is some
Levantine Arabic in our library at link
how is your relation with mr. I guess
I've never met him do you think you
knowing many languages gives you a huge
advantage in the job market not
necessarily it depends what job you're
looking for okay with that I'm gonna
leave because I want to spend a little
bit of time warming up for my Arabic
lesson which starts in 15 minutes thank
you everyone and we'll see you on Friday
bye for now